what's better than a friday night show
in las vegas not much
and some shows starting to come back as
our covid numbers begin to look better
and better thank you for joining us
tonight at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez now certain acts
at mgm and caesars properties have
started performing again
but not everyone is able to oracle mana
joining us now live from the las vegas
strip to explain why orco
well denise and brian there's no doubt
that the return of entertainment here on
the las vegas strip
is a huge step forward but even as
capacity restrictions are loosened
it's still not enough for some
performers
meet the soul juice band
singer david tatlock says the ban shows
that the house of blues inside mandalay
bay have been canceled for nearly a year
because of the covet 19 pandemic it's
been a really rough time
some performers are returning to the las
vegas strip because of the loosening of
restrictions the public gathering limit
was recently increased to 100 people or
35 percent capacity whichever is lower
and in march that set to go up to 50
percent
[Music]
but the soul juice band still has to
wait until it's economically viable for
the venue
house of blue is probably going to be 50
to 75 percent capacity
before we could start doing our you know
our twice a month show there
tatlock hopes that happens in april or
may but dr depauli kashup says the
timeline is hard to predict
the good news is that our infection
rates are going down and more vaccines
are being distributed
as more and more people keep getting
vaccinated it there is a spread of
immunity
and that's what we are seeing and will
continue to see tatlock is hoping for
the best
we're really looking forward to the
opportunities to start performing and
helping heal people with our music and
you know just be together again
now for the shows that have already
returned you can head to the specific
websites
of the properties they're at to get
tickets reporting live on the las vegas
strip tonight orca mana 8 news now